you heard from um secretary of state
we have now completed 19 million
first doses of vaccine we have given
those first
doses very successfully to cohorts
priority cohorts one to four and we're
moving at some speed
through cohorts five to six but these
are first
doses people do need a second dose
and given that the totality of the
cohorts one to nine the priority cohorts
is about 30 million people each of whom
need
two doses of vaccine by my rough
calculations
there are something like 40 million
doses still
to be given so
much as it's encouraging and much as i
am really very
upbeat about vaccines and how they are
going to
change how we live and and what the
disease is like between now and the
summer
there is a long way to go and
my inbox in the in in the last week
has been besieged with people writing in
saying i've had the vaccine essentially
can i now start to break the rules
can i go and see my grandchildren can i
do x y and z
and and the answer to that is no
we are not yet collectively as a country
in the right place and all the patients
that i vaccinate
and they'll know it if they're listening
on the tv i say to them and remember all
the rules
still apply to all of you and all of us
until we're in a much safer place it
doesn't change
because you've had your first dose of
vaccine and so
you know please don't be tempted to
think
uh well one home visit might be all
right now weather's getting better
going to be a nice weekend one small
gathering
in your house don't really matter i'm
afraid it does and
the the data on the slides speak for
themselves
so my kind of key message tonight is
look this is all going very well
but there are some worry signs that
people are
relaxing taking their foot off the brake
at exactly the wrong time it's a bit
like being three nil up in a game
and thinking well we can't possibly lose
this now but how many times have you
seen the other side take it 4-3
do not wreck this now it is
too early to relax just
continue to maintain discipline and hang
on just a few more months do not wreck
this
now we are so close